[Music]
synthetic rubber was invented in 1909
but the technology languished for a
couple of decades
a shortage of natural rubber during
world war ii spurred its development a
kind of elastic plastic it was actually
more resistant to temperature extremes
than natural rubber
synthetic rubber reinvented the wheel
we're talking about the rubber tire
tires for all kinds of vehicles are now
made from it
this man-made material is also used to
make everything from garden hoses to
golf balls
manufacturing synthetic rubber is now a
computerized process one that takes
place under the watchful eye of a
control room operator he monitors
numerous computer screens and live
camera images the plant itself is 437
yards long there are a dozen or more
enormous storage tanks for the raw
materials as well as several reactor
units the raw materials include a
petroleum-based liquid called butadiene
and solvent called hexane they pipe
these ingredients through columns to
boil off any residual water essentially
purifying them
this is a laboratory demonstration of
what happens next they combine the
purified butadiene and hexane and add a
catalyst
the catalyst triggers a reaction that
changes the chemistry the mix becomes
polybutadine a kind of synthetic rubber
used to make tires adding another
catalyst stops the reaction at just the
right moment
the white milky liquid that exits the
tank is synthetic rubber
they now pump in chemicals to tailor the
rubber for a specific use in this case
tires the additives will increase
traction and improve wear
a mechanized whisk stirs the additives
into the liquid rubber
they pipe the synthetic concoction into
insulated storage tanks inside pumps mix
it constantly so the additives don't
settle on the bottom here's a close-up
look at the liquid synthetic rubber in a
laboratory beaker it looks like a big
vanilla milkshake and it's about to be
coagulated into crumbs
here's where it all happens this
coagulation unit is like a big kettle
they pipe in the liquid rubber a solvent
mixture and water
as they boil off the solvent the rubber
coagulates into crumbs the size of beans
the water remains because it has a
higher boiling point the mix of water
and rubber crumbs bounces about in
what's known as the crumb tank until
it's time for more processing
they then pump the mix into a rotary
sieve as it spins it drains off the
water
they add more water to cool the rubber
crumbs
the rubber and water mix gushes onto a
conveyor which is a vibrating sieve
as the crumbs bounce along the water
drains off through the perforations in
the conveyor
the synthetic rubber is now a lot like
wet snow
[Music]
next it's into the lab where they aim a
beam of infrared light through a sample
to analyze the microstructure
if it's acceptable production continues
a screw-like mechanism presses the wet
rubber crumbs against a metal plate to
squeeze out more moisture
another trip on the next vibrating
conveyor drains off droplets
then it's into a quivering spiral
conveyor
as the synthetic rubber travels upwards
on the spiral hot air is piped in from
the side to dry it
now mostly devoid of moisture but still
sticky the synthetic rubber crumbs head
down a chute and into a baler machine
this machine uses pressure to compress
the crumbs into big bales
the bales of synthetic rubber head down
a conveyor towards a quality control
inspector
this inspector examines them for
imperfections
once he gives them the ok they head to
the packaging station
[Music]
as they travel through a curtain of
plastic film machinery heat seals it
around them
these bales of synthetic rubber have
taken about six hours to manufacture
and this purely chemical creation isn't
much different from the real thing like
natural rubber it can be melted and
shaped into many different things
soon this batch will be turned into
tires
and that's when the synthetic rubber
will really hit the road
[Music]
you